[Musique]
le sénat est touché par le coronavirus
une vague de tests sur une centaine de
personnes a révélé que 12 sénateurs et
collaborateurs étaient positifs l'un
d'entre eux serait hospitalisé le
restaurant du sénat a été fermée voulais
juste dire à monsieur le premier
ministre c'est dans ce qu'il est en
tirer en l'air dans les rues bondées
tous à l'envers ce qu il en train de
faire c'est ça voilà c'est d'un revers
de main en disant n'y aura pas
d'exception et en nous citant d'autres
cas en disant oui mais si je fais pour
vous je te réponds d'autres voilà ce
qu'on est en train de faire mais ce que
vous êtes en train de nous mettre par
terre
vous êtes en train de faire taire des
artistes vous êtes en train de demander
à des gens de renoncer à se divertir à
respirer à être un tout petit peu
heureux et à sortir de cette terreur
dans laquelle on est jean castex dans la
lessiveuse de matignon et bingo une
saloperie glissé en off au milieu du
papier à la campagne les gens voient
qu'il est mal sapés comme eux et ça
plaît
qui dit ça est bien une source anonyme
un maquereau nist de la première heure
qu'est vous êtes séduit aussi par ce
petit pas comme ça très séduits et très
intrigué parce que symbolique en deux
parties on a le bad de corps de
quelqu'un d'assez petit de taille
d'assez fin et on a le haut du corps de
rosine bachelot maintenant le soutien à
la culture je le mène est véritablement
oui mais pas question de démissionner
parce que vous avez aux contraintes ya
besoin
j'ai besoin de me battre j'ai besoin de
me suis pas désavoué
je me bats ya un débat on a pas de cas
de kloster dans les théâtres
alors voilà venez venez vous réfugier et
si on dépasse et sur des passes 21h et
vole on dort tous ensemble au théâtre ya
pas de problème
et s'ils ont le mot anxiogène angoisse
mon ami bouge à ce que je comprends très
bien moi y'en a un autre qui m'exaspère
c'est liberticide
voilà il ya une chose qui est
terriblement liberticide c'est la mort
voilà c'est la mort alors s'il faut
choisir entre faire du tarn ou ne plus
en faire pendant quatre ou cinq semaines
et mourir je choisis le confinement
est ce que vous vous intéressez à la
planète people ans maintenant rien à
[ __ ] merci donc je te dise est venu en
dehors du travail tout sera interdite
marché dans les rues se distraire
chanter danser voulant critiqué
l'instauration du couvre-feu nathalie et
bien nicolas dupont aignan a tweeté
cette phrase et il a attribué à georges
orwell
sauf que si l'on parcourt le célèbre
roman d'anticipation 1984 on s'aperçoit
que l'écrivain britannique n'a jamais
écrit cette phrase une fausse citation
donc le député de l'essonne et président
de debout la france a supprimé son tweet
depuis le début de l'épidémie les
pathologies psychologiques liées aux
coronavirus sont explosées à partir de
mi mars et surtout en avril mai juin
on a eu une grosse explosion des
téléconsultations aussi à peu près 250 %
d'augmentation pour de l'anxiété des
épisodes dépressifs des toques de
l'hypocondrie enfin vraiment l'impact
psychologique du coc vidé de la crise
pour les français il dure et il va durer
sur du long cours c'est chacun pouvait
appliquer la mesure cela la distance
dans les annales comme la maintenant
ouais et l'hygiène des mains
on arrête la transmission du virus on
n'en parle plus c'est à dire est
incroyable bien sûr mais dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire et de peurs
irraisonnées
fanny jacques a été confronté à des
comportements extrêmes
les patients vont développer des sortes
de toc de gestes barrières mais qui
n'ont pas de sens comme j'ai vu une
patiente vraiment se baigner faire des
bains de gel hydroalcoolique rien d'en
parler ça me rend nerveux qui font qu'à
boire un coup c'est du gel hydro
alcoolique c'est qu'on y mettra un peu
moins de gêne il serait plus goulet il
ya notamment à taiwan ils ont fait des
des applications quand on s'approche de
moins d'un mètre cinquante il ya un bel
outil sonne d'accord et et donc du coup
on se comprend pas à s'approcher sans
être averti qu'on s'approche
j'observe que le couvre-feu est une
mesure relativement bien accepté par nos
concitoyens alors qu'une semaine plus
tôt si elles avaient été annoncées
elle serait sans doute beaucoup moins
bien passé vous aurez souple est
d'accord vous les voulez j'ai constaté
je sais jeannois du que je vais rentrer
chez vous les policiers sont forcés de
faire demi tour car sans infraction
caractérisée
la loi leur interdit de pénétrer chez
les gens et j'aimerais quand même
rappeler à cette jeunesse de france que
l à une beaucoup de liberté encore une
liberté intérieure une liberté de
rêverie une liberté d'expression
d'opinion et que peut-être un local à
vous parler comme un vieux con alors
nous assez brutalement mais fidèle rêve
mort c'est que à l'occasion des martyrs
à l'occasion des usa alors que cette
privation
on mesure aussi ce que c'est que cette
liberté et comme elle est belle et la
chance qu'on a il reste plus beaucoup de
riz est en risque est coquillages on est
tous décidés à les manger est arrivé à
la réunification s'enraye
alors ouais ça peut choquer mais je m'en
fous c'est chacun pour sa peau
donc on va tous manger il va nous rester
débat ne ramènera des bananes et loïck
peyron c'est quand même n'importe qui à
qui je posais la question en disant donc
le célèbre navigateur et grand sportif
je disais mais qu'est le mal de mer
vraiment est ce qu'il faut manger bio il
faut manger et même je te conseillerais
de manger la banane
j pourquoi manger de la banane dit parce
que c'est le même goût quand sa rentrée
quand ça sort ça commence par il osé et
ça finit parfois en apothéose
en clair on vomit il ya des vagues
incroyables et puis surtout on sent
qu'elle en a sous la [ __ ]
les prises de respiration tu dois
pousser et appuyez sur ton sphincter on
sait déjà fera claudia truc c'est le
diaphragme
avez vous déjà été attirée physiquement
par une femme katherine heigl qu'elle
coming out vous parvenez à nouveau aimer
oui j'y arrive
j'arrivais mais différemment mère mais
je n'y ai toujours la jungle c'est un
courageux pour l'homme pour un homme
dans mais dans ma vie aujourd'hui qui la
place de johnny ton pour bien présenter
un c'est pas facile c'est pas facilement
non on est souvent un couple à 3 et
super cd
dans quelle émission devrions en huit
jours à rouvrir avant sa part roubaud
aussi je vous aime beaucoup robben enfin
pour rester calme quand même tu vois à
camille est des fois j'aimerais être à
temps plein